je sais qui vous êtes vous êtes l'avocat
c'est eux qui ont tué votre famille
n'ont eux c'est mon père
pantalon
et maintenant vous les traquer
alios
preuve que les cartes elles aident les
terroristes à passer la frontière
président ajoute les cartels de la
drogue la liste des organisations
terroristes vous imaginez bien que ça va
nous permettre d'étendre notre champ
d'action pour les combats ne voulait en
finir avec tout ça
valoir me laisser salir les mains c'est
exactement pour ça vous aidera à nous
aider à déclencher une guerre contre qui
tout
pas de limite cette fois
la première fois
votre objectif c'était de déclencher une
guerre entre les cartels mexicains
pas contre le gouvernement mexicain
cette gamine a été témoin de l'émission
c'est bien ça oui monsieur
on peut pas risquer qu'elles tombent
entre de mauvaises mains faites le
ménage une demande de rompre les liens
débarrasse toi d'elle je peux pas faire
ça ne me met pas dans cette situation
fait ce que tu as à faire je peux avoir
besoin d'une équipe de choc de deux
hélicos et de drones de combat dont coup
d'état ces eaux
pour mexique
aucune raison de me faire confiance
d'avoir confiance en moi te permettra de
rester en vie
bonne chance la chance n'existe pas ce
côté de la frontière
[Musique]